la base de loisirs de chemillé sur un
droit c'est 50 hectares de pur bonheur
on y vient en famille passer la journée
pédalos canoës pétanque châteaux de
sable et baignades dans le lac maillage
et manage avec la wii
d'autres embarquent à bord de leur
camping-car et rejoindre les copains
pour une après-midi de farniente
vraiment de gens qui viennent y a pas
d'argument de circulation les gens
viennent vraiment pour se détendre donc
ça permet de vraiment passer un moment
au calme c'est quoi le programme de la
journée du congrès
au programme ces pique-niques qu'on a
fait à midi repos 1e jouer ensemble et
puis peut-être mangé à la base de
loisirs de chemillé accueillant moyenne
cinquante mille personnes par an
beaucoup de locaux mais également des
touristes qui trouvent leur compte
l'objectif que l'on avait c'était
d'avoir une offre touristique un petit
peu différente de ce qui existe sur
notre secteur a donc on a beaucoup de
familles qui viennent une semaine en
gîte par exemple bon on s'est vite rendu
compte que quand ils auraient fait les
autres vos balles de trois châteaux
fallait trouver autre chose pour les
jeunes
et puis il fallait aussi quelque chose
de gratuit parce que le budget avait
déjà été pas mal entamée par les autres
activités
petite nouveauté cette année un parc
d'accrobranche
cinq parcours proposés et enfilait
trampoline de 500 m² pour des sensations
uniques ouvert à pâques le site a déjà
accueilli près de 2000 visiteurs en
l'espace de cinq mois à peine on a un
parc de 100 baudrier et il se trouve que
quand les sans baudrier sont utilisés
par les clients qui sont sur le site et
bien on a plus de place pour des gens
qui arrivent encore et on est sur un
principe on n'a pas de limite de temps
et on motive les gens à prévoir le
pique-niqué a passé la journée sur le
site qui est agréable comme vous pouvez
le voir donc un peu victimes de notre
succès c'est vrai et puis pour les plus
randonneurs d'entre vous sachez qu'il
est évidemment possible de faire le tour
du lac
si vous avez deux bonnes heures devant
vous